Female: Upon first
hearing that Salman Khan
would be speaking at
Castilleja during Global week,
my mind immediately went to
the famous Bollywood actor
who goes by the same name.
After seconds [paused],
I recognized the absurdity of the thought,
and realized who actually was coming.
While the Salman Khan, who joins us today,
might not possess flashy dance moves,
he is nevertheless a
world-renowned movie star
in his own right.
Salman, or Sal Khan, is the
founder of the Khan Academy,
a not-for-profit
organization that provides
a high-quality education for free
to anyone with internet access,
regardless of location,
social stratification, or age.
Sal has recorded over
1,000 YouTube videos,
available at khanacademy.org,
covering everything from
arithmetic and algebra
to calculus, physics,
chemistry, biology, and finance.
Sal personally helps more
than 70,000 students a month
from all over the world,
my family members included.
Whenever my sisters or I have a problem,
the first thing my parents tell us to do
is visit khanacademy.org.
Sal has successfully helped
me study for the SAT,
helped my older sister
prepare for the MCAT,
and help my younger sister understand
difficult chemistry concepts.
My mom even frequently visits the website
to learn more about the credit crisis,
and to brush up on her
differential calculus.
Before quitting his day
job in September of 2009
to work on the Khan Academy full-time,
Sal was a Senior Research Analyst
at a Bay Area investment fund.
He had previously held
positions in venture capital,
engineering, and product management.
He received his MBA from
Harvard Business School
where he was a student body president,
holds a master's degree and
a bachelor of science degree
in electrical engineering
and computer science,
and has a bachelor of science degree
in mathematics from MIT,
where he was President
of the Class of 1998.
What started as a way to
help his younger relatives
and family friends
understand course material
and do well in school,
has turned into a global sensation,
touching students from San Francisco,
Switzerland, Uganda, and beyond.
He received a 2009 Tech
Award in Education,
an award that honors innovators
from around the world
who apply technology to benefit humanity.
He has also appeared on the
Rick Sanchez Show on CNN
to explain the credit crisis,
spoken on NPR's "All Things Considered,"
and been interviewed in a recent
San Francisco Chronicle article.
In this article, Sal was quoted saying,
"With so little effort on my own part,
"I can empower an unlimited
amount of people for all time.
"I can't imagine a better use of my time."
Sal's dedication to educating
and enlightening the world,
free of cost, has inspired
[and aided] millions of people.
It is my pleasure to introduce Sal Khan.
(applause)
But first, he'll be showing
a video before he comes up.
(light music)
(applause)
Sal: Thank you for having me here.
It's incredibly exciting
on a whole set of levels.
I think the first thing that
makes it really exciting
to be here, in particular,
at Castilleja ...
Many of y'all may know it.
Some of y'all might not know it.
This was the first place
where I was taken seriously.
3 or 4 years ago, I was just this guy
working at a hedge fund,
who had this little
software that barely worked,
and I had a couple of videos on YouTube.
I wanted to get people, other than people
who I was maybe related to,
to actually use it. (laughter)
I approached Ryanne ... I guess
y'all call her Ms. Saddler.
She was the site director
for the Peninsula Bridge
here at Castilleja.
I tried to convince her.
"Hey, why don't y'all use this
"in the Peninsula Bridge Program?"
She was the first person
who essentially took
the Khan Academy seriously.
The talk I want to give today,
is really about how things can
start small, and how an individual,
with the tools that we
have on hand right now,
can do pretty far-reaching things.
You really can't underestimate the power
of those first few people
who believe in something,
and help you take it to the next level,
and make you feel like
it's a legitimate project.
My first visit to Castilleja
was a very positive one,
and actually played a very crucial role
in what you saw in that video.
Actually, Ryanne is
now on the board of ...
We have a 2-person board where ...
2-person board, and I'm
essentially the company.
(laughter) It's a fairly
small organization,
which is another theme I want to touch on
throughout this--what I want
to be more of a conversation
than a lecture or a talk.
One thing I want ... set the ground rules.
Raise your hand.
If something comes to mind,
or if you don't agree with something,
or if you just get
inspired, raise your hand,
and I'd be happy to address something,
or if I say something that confuses you.
The other reason why I'm
incredibly excited about being here
is, 1, I love the theme of Global Week,
especially that it's peace.
It's this notion that is ...
I think most people are afraid
to talk about things like peace
because it's such an audacious goal.
You almost feel that if you start thinking
in terms of world peace,
you're destined to fail.
We can get inspired here today,
but then when we turn on the news,
we're going to see people
talk angrily at each other.
We're going to probably
find out about some bombing,
or whatnot, in some place in the world.
It's very hard to tackle this subject.
I think it's a very impressive
thing to be tackling.
The other reason why it's incredibly
interesting to talk to y'all
is I think the people in this
room are in a unique position.
When I say in a unique position,
a unique position as
a function of your age
and a function of where we are in history,
that I think for the first time,
I can legitimately tell y'all
that you are in a position
to do something at least as
good as the Khan Academy.
We don't even know where the
Khan Academy is going to go,
but the tools now exist.
If 20 years ago, someone
like me was giving a talk
to myself when I was your age,
and they were to say, "Hey,
you could change the world,"
I would've rolled my eyes.
The best I could've done is
maybe had a signature campaign,
or sent a letter to a politician,
or volunteered in my local community,
which all would've been great,
but they wouldn't have
reached the threshold
of changing the world.
Now, I can stand here, and
legitimately tell y'all about my story,
and hopefully through
my story you'll realize
that you also have the tools at hand
to touch the world in ways
that we can't possibly imagine.
It really is a unique
opportunity based on the age
and your specific life experience.
I think y'all are in a
better position to do it
than large corporations
with millions of dollars,
or large governmental agencies,
or the UN, or whoever.
I think the people in this
room, using technology,
maybe the type of technology
I use with the Khan Academy,
or maybe other things,
really have the potential
to do amazing things.
What I want to talk about,
or give you the outline of this talk,
I'm going to tell you the
story of Khan Academy,
but the whole point of
telling you this story
is to put yourself in my shoes as someone
who's doing something
interesting for them,
rewarding on a very small scale.
I want you to take in the
experience of how it happens,
how it's a very organic,
that it's not like I
just sat down one day,
and I wrote on paper, "I
want to educate 80,000 people
"in the world, or 80 million
people in the world, or bust.
"If I don't do that,
then I'm a big failure."
I started off very small,
with very small goals,
really to just impact a
very small set of people,
all of whom I happen to be related to.
It slowly had grown into something more.
I'm going to tell you the
story about Khan Academy.
You got a little bit of
a tidbit right there.
After that, I want to talk a little bit
about what that means for education.
That's another reason
why it's neat to be here.
This is a school.
What could be a more
interesting discussion
than where education is going?
I think Khan Academy
might play a role in it,
but I think there are some
trends that are going to happen,
whether or not the Khan Academy ...
if I got hit by a bus,
God forbid, outside.
(laugther)
Regardless of what
happens with Khan Academy,
there are things that I
think are going to occur.
I think they're going to
occur in the next 10-15 years.
I think it's a very
interesting discussion to have.
Then finally ... I have
attended, when I was young,
a lot of talks that inspired me,
and I wanted to go out and change
the world and start a revolution.
I would be all inspired, and
have all this inspiration,
and I would go home, and I
would just twiddle my thumbs,
and not know what to do
with myself and my energy.
I had a friend who was a hardcore athlete.
He always told me, "Never
waste inspiration."
What I want to do ...
It's actually a very valuable
commodity, so it shouldn't be wasted.
What I want to do at the end of
this talk is throw out ideas.
I don't want to just tell
you my story, and say,
"Look, you can change
the world. Now, go home."
What I want to do is say, "Look. I
did this, really almost by chance."
Here's 4 or 5 things you all could do.
These are really just
to be seeds in your head
of stuff that you could work on.
You might think they're horrible ideas,
but hopefully it'll at least
get your juices flowing
on ways that you might be
able to impact the world.
To start off, you got a
little tidbit right there.
4, 5 years ago, I was a newly-minted MBA.
I was working at a hedge fund.
It's kind of a bad word now,
but not all hedge funds are evil.
(laughter) Many are, though. (laughter)
My portfolio manager,
who is a vegetarian ...
If we made money off of an egg company,
he would donate his profits
to fight abusive chickens.
I have not made this up.
We were a more ethical hedge fund.
I was a newly-minted MBA,
working as a hedge fund analyst in Boston.
I had just gotten married in New Jersey.
I had some family that
wanted to visit me in Boston,
my aunt and uncle, and their children;
Nadia, Armand, and Ali.
Nadia was the oldest.
She was 12 years old at the time.
They visited me just to see
Boston, take in the sights.
It was exciting for me
because it was the first time
that I really got to spend
time with my cousins.
When I was in New Orleans ...
They were from New Orleans.
I grew up in New Orleans.
When I was there before high
school, they were toddlers,
and I never had really a
serious discussion with them,
or I never really was
able to bond with them.
Now, when they visited me in
Boston, for the first time,
I was really able to connect with them.
Nadia especially impressed me.
I think this story is
especially interesting,
talking to many of you all,
because when I look out into the audience,
I see a lot of Nadias.
I see a lot of bright,
motivated young women who ...
In Nadia's case, as soon as I
spent a couple hours with her,
talking to her about life
and what she wanted to do,
and politics, and philosophy,
and I would give her brain teasers.
She was just ultra sharp, and here was I.
I thought I was this
reasonably-sophisticated
25 or 26 year old,
and I literally could
talk to her as an equal.
Sometimes, I felt like I was
a little bit out of my league.
I was just wildly impressed by her.
You can imagine. I think it's ...
You've probably experienced this
a little bit with your own parents.
When you have a ... When
you meet a young person,
who you're very impressed by,
who you think has a lot of potential,
you have this natural inclination
to have them follow in your footsteps.
Everyone thinks that what they do
is the best possible thing.
While we were touring around
Boston, we visited MIT.
When I was visiting MIT, I told Nadia,
and the whole family was there.
I said, "Nadia, I know there's probably
"all these stereotypes in your head
"that make you not think that
you want to go to this school,
"and it has this [unintelligible],
"but I generally think, based
on interacting with you ...
"You're creative. You show
this analytical ability.
"I really think ... I'm just going
to put this seed in your head.
"You don't have to do it. No pressure,
"but I really think this
would be a good place
"for you to think about coming to.
"Maybe you'd want to be an engineer,
"and become an engineer, and then one day,
"work at a hedge fund, but a
good hedge fund." (laughter)
If any of you all are
interested in that career path,
talk to me afterwards. (laugther)
I'll be your personal counselor.
She kind of, I think, did
what a lot of y'all would do
when your mom or dad tries to
get you into the family business.
She rolled her eyes a little bit and said,
"Thanks, but I don't know about it.
"I was thinking of becoming
a journalist, or something."
I don't know if I really
got a lot of traction,
but when I said that,
at the same time that
I was talking to Nadia
about possibly coming to MIT,
I saw my aunt and uncle
give each other a look,
a look like, "What's Sal talking about,
"asking our Nadia to go to MIT?"
I didn't know how to interpret that look.
I thought maybe it's another one
of these stereotypical things
about women in technical fields,
and engineering, or whatever.
Maybe it was something deeper. Who knows?
Maybe it was just my
aunt was mad at my uncle
for some other random reason. (laughter)
I didn't know, but it caught my eye.
The next morning, before
everyone else had woken up,
my aunt [unintelligible] had come to ...
We were just hanging out.
Everyone else was still asleep.
She said, "Sal. I can't
tell you how great it is
"that you're a bit of a
role model for my children.
"They really look up to you.
"They're enjoying this trip tremendously.
"I can't tell you how
much it's affecting them.
"They're getting inspired to do things.
"They all want to come to
Boston to go to college.
"They love the area."
She said, "The one thing
you probably don't know,
"and it's concerning us, and
it's been an issue in the family
"is that Nadia's actually
having a lot of difficulty
"in math right now, and
she was actually placed
"into the slower track in her ...
"as she goes into 7th grade.
"They didn't place her into the track
"that would allow her to
take algebra in 8th grade,
"and then progress on that track."
I think many of you are
on ... that allows you
a college preparatory track,
where you take calculus
in high school, whatnot.
For me, this was obviously surprising.
I just told you how impressive Nadia was.
Sometimes when I would speak to her,
I felt like I was speaking to
someone out of my own league.
For me to think that in 6th grade,
there was something that
was tripping her up.
It was almost hard for me to believe.
When Nadia woke up, I [pulled her].
I was like, "Hey, your mom
says you're having an issue
"with something in mathematics.
"What do you think is the situation?"
She says, "I just don't get units."
She just doesn't get kilograms to
milligrams, or pounds to ounces.
It does. It gives all of us
a little bit of a headache,
but she just didn't get it.
She says, "When I see those problems,
"my brain just shuts down, and
I just think it's beyond me."
I told her. I said, "Nadia, let's
do a deal. You're here for ..."
actually another ... I think it
was the last day of their visit.
"You're going to leave tomorrow,
go back to New Orleans,
"but I am 100,000% convinced
that you are well capable
"of learning units, and
I actually suspected
"you're capable of learning
things far deeper than units,
"but it's just my suspicion.
"Why don't we do some
type of remote tutoring?
"You go back to New Orleans.
"We'll get on a speakerphone.
"We'll get some pen tablets, maybe.
"We'll find something
that where we can write.
"We can both see. We're each writing,"
and she agreed.
I think she was, 1,
excited about this idea
of having someone
interested in her directly,
and giving her that 1-on-1 attention,
and someone to be able to connect with.
I was kind of like her older brother.
But on the other level, I think she was
a little bit daunted by the idea.
It was a little extra
pressure above and beyond
what you already have from school
and being a middle
school ... a young woman,
which a lot of pressures that
y'all are probably facing
on some dimension right now.
It's actually very strange to
be talking to y'all about Nadia,
because I keep realizing that
a lot of y'all are Nadia,
or in some way have elements
that are similar to her.
It adds a whole new level
to this conversation.
She agreed. Within a week,
we both had our pen tablets.
She was in New Orleans. I was in Boston.
I would come home from work,
right after the market closed.
I would call her up.
She would be done with all of her ...
I think she was on the
basketball team at the time.
We would start doing these sessions.
I've got to tell you, the
first week was painful.
The tone of the conversation ...
When we were just speaking
as friends, or as relations,
it was a dynamic conversation,
really intelligent,
really engaging, really fast-paced,
but as soon as we entered
this domain of units,
which was our first subject to tackle ...
As soon as we entered that domain,
I felt like she just shut down.
I would ask her a question.
"How many kilometers would that be?"
There would be this long pause.
I didn't know if I lost her on the line,
if something happened with
our internet connection.
Then, her answers were always
in the form of a question.
They were always like, "100? 10?"
I had no idea. I said,
"Nadia, are you guessing?"
It was just very difficult.
I could imagine if it was painful for me,
it was probably 10-times
as painful for her
because above and beyond
this being a subject
that she was struggling with,
and we all have had that feeling
of struggling with something.
She was working with her cousin,
who she probably wanted to impress
because he was already impressed by her.
He already believes in her.
She probably felt all this anxiety
of being judged, and what not.
Literally, after a week of
this, I started questioning
whether this made sense,
whether I had done more harm than good,
She was already having difficulty,
and I was getting pretty
close to giving up on her
just because it felt like
we had made no headway
in a week after 5 sessions.
I made a last-ditch effort.
The next conversation
I had with her, I said,
"Nadia. I know you're smart.
"I know it by based on
interacting with you,
"and we also share a certain
amount of DNA. (laughter)
"That, by itself, is proof enough.
"I am not judging you.
"I am not judging you in
no way, shape, or form.
"You need to view me as a
resource, purely as a resource.
"There is nothing that you can ask me,
"that in any way, will
make me think less of you.
"In fact, the more questions you ask,
"will make me think more of you.
"I need you to be completely honest
"when you don't understand something.
"When I ask a question, either say,
"'I do not know the answer
to that question, Sal.
"'Please explain it,' or
answer in the affirmative.
"Don't say, 'Ten?' Say, 'Ten,'
"or say, 'I do not understand.
"Just be a little bit more
engaging," and it worked.
Over the next week, because
she started giving me
more information about what
it exactly was in her brain,
that was having trouble with units,
I was able to hone in a little bit better,
and address those small points
of confusion that she had.
When do you multiply? When do you divide?
I think that's the
confusion many people have
with concepts of units.
You're always multiplying and
dividing by different things.
But, she got it.
Once she got it, it was fascinating
because something clicked in her head.
Not only did she go from
thinking that it was this huge,
intractable, impossible thing to do.
She went to thinking that it was easy.
She thought it was so
easy, and so intuitive,
that she was almost angry about it.
She was angry that something
that she now found,
3 weeks later, to be intuitive,
and easy, and natural.
She was angry that this was
potentially derailing her career,
derailing her self-impression,
or not allowing her to proceed
with her other friends into
the normal-track math class.
I want to take a side
here, from Nadia's story,
because I think that experience ...
and I don't know if any of
y'all have experienced it yet.
Hopefully you will.
I've experienced it
multiple times in my life,
where you have this intractable problem
that you're almost ready to give up,
that you just think your brain is
not built for this type of problem.
When you're faced with
something like that,
most people give up, and the
rest of their life they think,
"I'm not meant to do algebra.
"I'm not meant to do calculus.
"I'm not meant to do physics."
I used to know people on the other side.
"I'm not meant to be a writer.
"I'm not meant to ... I'm a slow reader."
Whatever it might be, we all face this,
and most people tend to give up.
That experience of facing
it once in your life,
and then overcoming it,
and overcoming it in a way
that you realize that it's
actually an easy thing,
that's tremendously powerful.
I think it's tremendously
transformational.
I encourage you all to try to
have those type of experiences,
to try to really engage with things
that you find intractable right now,
because I guarantee you, at the
age that you're at right now,
if you discover that it
really is not so intractable,
and if you really can
overcome that hurdle,
the rest of your life, you won't
really find anything to be impossible.
You're going to realize that
you just have to engage,
and be aggressive, and
find the right resources
with enough energy and
things will work out.
Nadia--to make a long story short--
she just progressed tremendously.
From then on, once she figured out
that if she just engaged enough
that she would be able to
understand the concepts.
We just keep proceeding forward.
After a month or two, I said,
"Nadia, the stuff we're covering now,
"this is stuff that not only
you would normally expect
"of a smart, or an
advanced, 7th or 8th grader.
"This is material that you would expect
"of a advanced 9th or 10th grader."
From then on, and since then ...
This was in 2004, 2005 that we started.
Nadia just turned into a rock star.
She ended up taking ... or
maybe I should say a mathlete.
(laughter) She ended up ...
I don't want to give you the impression
that I think this is
the measure of a person
of what math classes they take,
and what year, and all of that.
I want to give you a very tangible example
of someone who I saw firsthand,
who went from someone
who was ready to give up
on mathematics at the age of 12 or
13, to someone who took calculus
when she was a freshman in high school,
who ended up having to go to
the University of New Orleans
when she was a sophomore
because they had run out
of math classes at her high school.
But, at the same time, she now
still wants to be a writer.
This isn't something where ...
She's actually going to
go to Sarah Lawrence,
and she wants to be a
writer, and God bless her.
She didn't want to be an engineer
and a hedge fund manager,
(laughter) but this is
the important thing.
She didn't become a writer.
I think in a lot of Asian, in a lot of ...
My family is originally from South Asia.
In our culture, there's this notion of,
"Oh, they're becoming a
writer because they couldn't
"be an engineer, or because
they couldn't be a doctor."
In Nadia's example, she can say,
"Oh yeah. Well, I could've been
one, but I'm deciding to do this."
I think it's super important
for people to have that option,
for her to know that she made
the decision to be a writer
as opposed to being forced into it
because when she was in 6th grade,
she had given up on mathematics.
After Nadia's story, I've got to tell you.
That was probably the
most rewarding experience
in my life up to date.
You can imagine. I was a
guy working at a hedge fund.
It's an intellectually-stimulating job,
but it's a job where it's
hard to answer the question
of what did you do for humanity today?
I actually used to have this
rationalization [as well].
In a Communist system, you
have these central planners
who like to allocate the capital,
but in the Capitalist system
you need people participating
in the market to make sure that
prices are set efficiently,
and only when prices are set efficiently,
can capital be allocated efficiently,
and because of that,
people will be better off.
That was my rationalization
for working at a hedge fund.
As you could imagine, it's
a convoluted argument,
and it would always make
my wife roll her eyes.
To be able to come home and touch
someone in a meaningful way,
someone who I was related to,
and feel that I was impacting
her life's trajectory,
tremendously satisfying.
I decided I wanted to keep going.
I started with her younger
brothers, Armand and Ali.
Then, I started with some other
cousins, other family friends.
This is really, now we're
going into 2005, early 2006.
I had this cohort of
about 15 or 20 students
that I would use ... I tried
to replicate the Nadia model.
I would get on a conference call,
and we would use Yahoo! Doodle
to write with each other,
and to see what we're doing.
As you could imagine, [unintelligible]
just getting very hard to scale up.
I had the luxury with Nadia of
having this 1-on-1 interaction.
Even when I started having small groups
of 2 or 3 students at the same time,
it just became completely
different, hard to scale,
but I thought really hard.
How can I ... that same
thing that I did with Nadia,
how can I somehow scale it up?
How can I print out
more versions of myself,
so that other people could
interact in the same way.
One thing I did, is I started
writing some software.
It was fun for me, again,
because I had given up
my computer science part of my
brain to go work in finance,
so it was just a fun project for me.
The whole goal of the software was
to be able to hone in on that weak point,
to automate that process that I had,
that question-and-answer
process that I had with Nadia,
where I was able to realize, oh,
she just doesn't get
this more basic concept,
and that's why she was having
trouble with the idea of units.
I wrote a little bit
of software like that,
and I put a little database behind it,
so that I could keep track, what
the students were working on.
My cousins, they liked it.
They enjoyed the fact that it
was generating problems for them,
and they could practice,
but the harder problem ...
and this is what really directly led
to where the Khan Academy is now,
is how do we schedule
time with each other,
or how can I teach all of these students?
I only had 20 right
now, but it was already
becoming too much for me,
in a way that they could
learn at their own pace,
they could learn at their own time.
That's where the idea ...
and it really wasn't my idea.
I have to give credit to
a friend of mine who said,
"Hey, why don't you just put
some stuff up on YouTube?"
I have to say, my own pride, right?
When he said that, I
was like, "No, no, no.
"My software is enough. YouTube vidoes ...
"My software is so good,
it gives people hints,
"and it's web-based,
and it has a database,
"and you should see the database."
After I got over the fact that
I didn't think of the idea,
(laughter) I said, "Look, maybe I'll try
"some of these YouTube videos."
The very first YouTube video I
did was a least common multiple,
so if you watch that video, it's
by far the most rough video.
Hopefully it'll be a part of
history one day. (laughter)
I made that video, and my
cousins and family friends,
who needed to learn the
least common multiples,
they actually said they
really liked it because ...
Actually, one of them told me ...
and this was a bit of a
backhanded compliment.
I didn't know what to think of it.
They said, "Oh, I like
you better on YouTube."
(laughter)
It's actually funny.
He was the first person to say it,
but I got that feedback
over and over again.
I think the core issue of why
I'm better on YouTube is 1,
there isn't this stress when
you have this interaction
with a tutor or a teacher of,
"Hey, do you get this?"
You're kind of like, "Oh,
gee. He's looking at me."
I'm sorry. You were just
standing right there,
(laughter) so you have to ...
But, it's hard to think when
someone is waiting for you
to process something
that you're just learning
to get your hands around.
Maybe I said something
that you don't understand,
but you don't want to ask me
because it's a basic concept,
and you want me to think that
you're a smart individual,
but this is something that
you really should've mastered
probably in 4th or 5th grade,
and you're in 9th grade now.
If you tell me that you
really don't know ...
Dividing decimals is still
this little gray area,
and if dividing decimals
actually is, you're not alone.
I actually want to go to a mall one day,
and just see how many
adults ... (laughter)
That's a whole ... I can't
tell you how many letters I get
from all sorts of people,
all walks of life,
that dividing decimals is the one thing
that no one wants to admit
that they forgot how to do,
but it's a huge need [unintelligible] ...
But anyway, that's a ... I
go on tangents. (laughter)
I was talking about why
I'm better on YouTube
is that you can pause me.
You can repeat me.
If I say something you don't understand,
you can go to Wikipedia,or
go to some other site,
or go to one of my other videos,
and get that concept filled in.
There's no stress. You're
doing it at your own time.
I actually got a letter
from a college student once.
He wrote me ... I can't tell
you how valuable this is.
He said, "I actually have a
very good calculus professor,
"but our class is at 7 in
the morning on a Monday,
"and when I'm there,
there's this cute girl
"who sits two rows in front of me.
"All I can think about all day,
throughout the entire class
"is whether I'm going to have
the guts to walk up to her
"after class and ask her out.
"I think about whether
I want to write memoirs
"about what I did last
weekend." (laughter)
By the time all those thoughts go on,
he's completely missed the calculus class
at 7 in the morning,
and then he goes home, and he
watches the YouTube videos.
His story, it's actually very realistic.
It's what happens all the
time in the model that's ...
In the standard model, you're learning,
you and the teacher in a room
that's dictated by some schedule.
It has to be, based on logistics.
It's no one's fault, really.
If I had to teach you a concept
everyday at 7 in the morning,
sometimes I'm not going
to be on my A-game.
I'm not going to be
super passionate about it
because teachers are people, too.
Sometimes it's hard to ... (laughter)
It's hard for the teacher sometimes,
and it's especially hard
for the student to engage,
especially if there's some other thing
that they're thinking
about, or they're sleepy,
or there's some core concept that
they missed in the last class.
This idea of being able
to get something on demand
is tremendously useful, and
once I got that feedback
from my cousins and family friends,
I made more videos.
At first, I put the videos up.
[Obviously], I expected about
10 or 20 people to watch them,
but slowly, people that
weren't related to me,
or who didn't know me personally,
started watching them,
and that kept growing.
I got excited.
I don't know, how many of
y'all have seen the movie,
"Julie and Julia?" Have you?
Okay, when I was watching that movie,
I felt like this is like ...
on some metaphysical level,
I felt some ... It was actually,
I didn't want to watch it.
I thought it was about
cooking, or something.
I didn't realize it was about
someone who started a blog
that became very popular.
That experience she had where
she keeps pressing "refresh,"
and she's amazed that someone,
other than her mother,
actually read her blog.
That was me. That was me 4 years ago.
I put a video up, and I
would keep refreshing it.
I still do this. I'm not as
secure as I might appear to be.
(laughter)
I keep refreshing it
until I get some feedback.
Something, either the
little YouTube people rate,
if they give it 5 stars,
I'm very sensitive.
If someone even gives 4 stars,
I question whether I'm
doing the right thing,
and whether I should go back
to finance, and what not.
(laughter) It's a very
emotionally-trying experience.
But, I keep refreshing, and I wait
to see some positive feedback.
Eventually, someone will
just say, "Thank you."
As soon as they say thank you, it's like,
"Oh, good. This was
somewhat useful to somebody.
"I'll record the next video now."
(laughter) I can't tell you
how valuable that notion is.
More and more people kept watching it
over the course of the next few years.
It grew roughly 20% a month,
and if y'all are familiar with
the compounding of growth,
that's actually a very fast rate.
You're growing several fold every year.
Now, as I was thankfully introduced,
it's reaching, actually [on the order]
of about 100,000 students now a month,
and 40,000 video views a day.
What's really exciting about it
is that's just a small sliver of people
who just happened to
have found out about it
through word of mouth, or
through friends and family,
or through the blogisphere.
Someone might have written about it.
It's a very small sliver
of, I think, the people
who could benefit from
something like this.
On top of the 100,000 people,
it's still mind-boggling to me
when I say these numbers.
Here I am, just sitting in my pajamas,
recording YouTube videos all day.
While I'm having breakfast, or at work ...
I didn't quit my job until 3 months ago.
While I was at work, or sleeping,
somebody around the world
is learning from me.
They're being empowered on some level.
This is what I think is the
most important ingredient
in the theme of peace, of
that individual empowerment.
and it's happening with
no effort on my part,
no cost to me, nothing I'm doing,
but that person is getting empowered.
It's like a perpetual motion machine.
It's like you're making gold out of lead.
It's like creating
something out of nothing.
That idea, to me, is still mind-boggling.
It didn't have to be 100,000 people.
Just the idea that it's even 1 person
that it's happening for is
even mind-boggling to me.
Then, when you throw out
numbers, like 100,000,
or we've had 9 million [unintelligible],
I have trouble even completely
understanding what that means,
but it just amazes me.
Out of the blue ... Once again,
I want this narrative to show you
how organically things can happen.
Out of the blue, I got
a letter from somebody
who distributes computers
in Uganda, and said,
"We distribute these computers,
"and we don't have any internet access,
"but we love the Khan Academy videos.
"We've seen some of the
students interact with them.
"They love them. How
can we get these videos
"to these students in Uganda?"
I had no idea.
I was just recording YouTube videos.
The very next email ... This is why ...
I'm not the most religious
person on the planet,
but sometimes things
happen in certain ways,
where you think, "Gee,
there's some aliens,
"or something, controlling what's
happening to me," [laughter]
but the very next email was
this group of volunteers,
from Cisco Systems, that said,
"Hey, we like your videos.
"We view them as a K-12 school-in-a-box
"for children who don't have
access to good teachers.
"Why don't we ... Can
we download your videos,
"and put them on hard disks,
"and distribute it to other groups?"
I said, "Yeah, not only can you do that,
"but there's this other
guy who just emailed me
"literally 4 minutes ago.
"Why don't you send him a hard drive?"
Literally, in about 4
minutes of forwarding emails,
I got a letter from the group.
It's called [viewconnect.org],
in Uganda, a week later, saying,
"We have the hard drive from that group
"at Cisco, [World Possible]."
Literally, it just happened
with a couple of email forwards,
"and the kids in Uganda love it."
I did nothing. (laughter)
I did absolutely nothing.
I forwarded a couple of
emails between people.
We're at this period in
... and I want this ...
This is my story, but I
want you to think about
this could kind of be your story as well,
because we're at this point
in where technology is,
and how society is getting interconnected,
where people are just waking up,
and they're realizing, "Gee.
That's there. That's there.
"If we put those two things together,
"and take it over there, that's free gold.
"We're turning lead into gold
with no cost for anybody."
I think Khan Academy is
just one small sliver
of what could be done.
I think there's a whole set of dimensions.
I think the people in this room
probably could think of ...
You've been immersed in this from ...
You're immersed in it right now,
in whatever you want to call it, web 2.0.
You understand this.
It makes sense to you.
I think there's no reason
why everyone in this room
couldn't do something similar,
although I don't know in
what form it might take.
We can talk more about that later.
Khan Academy, that's the organic story
of how it happened, how I ended up here.
Somewhere in there, I
showed up with the software
and the videos at Ryanne's office.
I said, "Can you use this
for the Peninsula Bridge?"
At first, she's like,
"Does it work on Macs?
"Because we only have Macs. If
it doesn't work on Macs ..."
(laughter) Actually, it didn't
work on Macs at the time,
but I said, "Well, I think it does."
It's a little part of salesmanship
you have to learn early on.
(laughter) Anyway. If you think, it's
not necessarily [unintelligible].
(laughter) Anyway. We
got it working on Macs.
It was used at Peninsula Bridge.
Actually, that was a tremendously
powerful experience there,
because at Peninsula Bridge,
we saw that pattern that I saw with Nadia.
There's a chart. Actually,
I'll show the chart.
Well, I won't show the chart.
It's small and all of that.
The big takeaway ... and this leads
into where education is going.
Right now, when you learn,
there's just snapshots.
You get assessed at certain
points in your life.
Those assessments tell you
whether you're good at math
or bad at math, or good at
reading or bad at reading.
What we saw when we
dealt with the students
at Peninsula Bridge, who had a
whole spectrum of backgrounds,
is that when you started
everyone at 1+1=2,
and then let them progress
at their own pace,
that there were some students who had
just very, very basic deficiencies.
They just didn't understand
negative numbers,
or they didn't understand borrowing,
or I guess it's called regrouping,
or however you want to call it.
They didn't understand
subtracting numbers.
In a traditional learning model,
when those students get to algebra ...
I think they were rising
7th or 8th graders.
You could have the best
algebra teacher on the planet,
and you can be the smartest
student on the planet,
but if you are having a basic weakness
in negative numbers,
or subtracting numbers,
that conversation, you're just
going to be talking past each other.
The teacher's going to get frustrated.
The teacher's going to wonder
what they're doing wrong.
The student's going to wonder,
"Why do I not get this when
everyone else gets this?"
The main issue is this core weakness,
very early on in their careers,
that can't be addressed the way
the current system is structured.
Once again, it's no one's fault.
It's all a by-product of being
able to get people in a room,
and being able to have one
teacher teach 10, 20, 30 students.
But, the exciting thing is
over the next 10, 15 years,
through technology, I think
some of this can be addressed.
When I talk about technology,
I don't want to give anyone the impression
that I want to take the
human out of the equation.
I think it's the opposite.
I think what technology
will allow us to do
is let the human be the human,
and the technology will
take away all the minutia,
take away all of the things that
it's hard for a teacher to do,
whether it's writing
exams, or grading papers,
or trying to assess what the core
weak points are in a student.
Let the technology do that,
and then let the teacher
go in and be that mentor,
be what I was with Nadia.
Guide them and really focus,
and give them that
instruction that the videos
and the software could never do.
I want to make that very clear.
Sometimes people see me as this background
about potentially robot.
I'm the kind of guy that people think
wants robots to take over
the world, and whatever.
(laughter) Nothing can be
further from the truth.
One question I get a lot from,
especially when I started off,
was people asking, 1,"Why
are you doing this?"
And 2, "How do you know
that this is working?"
I have a lot of data, and
I could show you the data,
but that would bore you.
The single-biggest thing that
I think has been motivating me,
and I think has proved that it's working
is some of the letters I get.
I'll just read a couple of letters.
I feel a little bit
awkward about doing this
because it's kind of self-praise.
My wife has made me very
conscientious about self-praise.
(laughter) I want you to think
of how I would feel reading this,
working at a hedge fund,
where all day, the best thing I could get
is maybe a couple extra
dollars bonus from my boss.
He never writes me a letter
like this. (laughter)
Let me read. These are mind-blowing.
The point here is I want you to realize
that Internet and web technologies
can touch people in
tremendously meaningful ways.
"Hello, Sal. My
12-year-old son has autism,
"and has had terrible time with math.
"We've tried everything, viewed
everything, bought everything.
"Well, we stumbled across
your video on decimals,
"and it got through. Then we
went onto dreaded fractions.
"Again, he got it. We couldn't believe it.
"He was so excited. It's your
soothing voice and calm manner,"
(laughter)
"coupled with an easy-going
explanation and examples.
"I can't say thank you
enough. You are a hero."
Once again, I didn't jump
into a burning building.
I didn't save someone's
kitten from a rooftop.
I'm not G.I. Joe. (laughter)
This person--while I'm sleeping,
or eating lunch, or at work
analyzing financial statements
for my hedge fund --
this person is calling me a hero,
with no extra effort [unintelligible].
Here's another one.
I'll just read this one.
This one is almost ... When I read this,
this is pretty much what sealed the deal
for me to quit my job.
I got this in August of '09,
and I quit 2 weeks later,
just because I realized if people
are being touched in this way,
I've got to be able to figure
out a way to do this full-time.
"Mr. Khan. No teacher
has done me any good.
"This may sound harsh, but
I mean it quite literally.
"I was force-fed medication
to keep me from talking,
"and chastised for not
speaking out when called on.
"Where I'm from, blacks are not welcome
"with open arms into schools.
"My mother and her sisters
had to go to a small shack,
"2 hours from home, when
they went to school.
"About 5 years ago, my
family collected enough money
"to move from where I was born,
"so that I could have a
chance at an education,
"and living a real life.
"But, without a real
mastery of elementary math,
"I was slow to progress.
"I am now in college, and learning more
"than I ever have in my life.
"But an inadequate math background
"has been holding me back.
"I found the Khan
Academy in June of 2009."
This is literally 6 months ago.
"Right after I had completed Math-141,
"a college algebra course,
"I spent the entire summer
on your YouTube page.
"I just wanted to thank you
for everything you're doing."
Once again, "You are a Godsend."
I don't know what to even say.
That makes me feel awkward. (laughter)
"Last week, I tested for
a math placement exam,
"and I am now in Honors Math-200."
This is the [unintelligible].
"No question was answered incorrectly."
This goes from someone
... It's mind-blowing.
"My placement-test holder was so impressed
"by the breadth of my knowledge of math,
"that he said I should
be in linear algebra.
"Mr. Khan, I can say, with any doubt,
"you've changed my life and the
lives of everyone in my family."
This is happening through the Internet.
This is something you can reach people.
It doesn't have to be through education.
I think any time that
you interact with people,
and they can see humanity,
you are fostering world peace.
I want to finish off with
things that you can do.
I promise I would throw
out some tangible ideas.
The first thing is y'all
could do exactly what I did,
teach things, even teach mathematics.
Different types of teachers,
people respond to different types
of instruction all of the time.
Your take on things
might connect with people
and you in innovative ways.
Teach English. There's no
better way to empower people
in the developing world to participate
in the global economy
than learning English.
That's something I think
everyone in this room could do.
Set up Skype buddies, so that
you can start interacting
with people across the world.
Even better, try to get
people in Iran and Israel
to interact with each other,
or Pakistan and India to
interact with each other.
That is very tangible world peace.
That's something that you can go home,
right now, and do from your living room.
You could ... One idea
that I threw out ...
Record videos, little
screenplays, 3-minute videos,
and I think everyone in
this room collectively
could get the job done
in a couple of weeks,
where y'all just use SAT words.
Use them flagrantly. (laughter)
The idea being ... It would be cheesy,
and it would be silly, and
it would be ridiculous,
but I guarantee you, 1, to the
process of making those videos,
you're going to do a lot better
on the SAT verbal section,
but even more importantly,
it'll be used by your peers,
probably future young women at Castilleja,
and even more interestingly,
I guarantee you, if they
are smart, and funny,
but rough, and genuine, and human,
that people all over the world,
very likely will start to use it,
and you will be empowering
them to perform well
on things that really do matter.
Hopefully, through my story ...
and you do appreciate this idea
that y'all are in a position
to go home right now,
without millions of dollars,
without governmental support,
to start something that has the potential,
over the next 5-10 years,
to touch millions of people.
Even if it doesn't touch millions
of people, you should ...
If it just touches your direct community,
and your direct friends and family,
that alone makes it worthwhile.
I thank y'all very much for having me.
I'm open to any questions.
(applause)
If anyone has any questions or ...
Oh. Yeah?
Female: Do you think that
you'll ever do anything
like history lessons or English
lessons in Khan Academy?
Sal: Yes. That's actually on
my to-do list on my whiteboard.
I want history lessons,
1, just because I think
there's this huge gap
between the news and what goes
on in history class right now,
where the news is these
30-second sound bites,
and history class, you start off
with Mohenjo-daro and Harappa.
If you're lucky, you
might get to World War 2.
There's this huge gap between that and ...
I don't think that happens
here at Castilleja.
I never got beyond World
War 2 in my history.
That leaves this huge
gap in why is the world
the way it is right now?
Actually, I would like
to do a little 10 minutes
on Israel and Palestine conflict,
10 minutes on Indian ...
Obviously, these are very touchy issues,
and I'm going to have a
lot of caveats out there.
I actually have a whole set of videos
on intelligent design and evolution.
I keep [unintelligible].
I don't want to skew your opinion.
But anyway, I do intend to do that.
I do want to do grammar.
I want to do everything.
I think all of y'all should join in.
Female: Sorry.
Female: How do you know so
much on all of these subjects?
(laughter)
Sal: My wife would be
rolling her eyes right now.
(laughter) There's a small set of things
that I do know based on my background.
I was a mathlete in high school,
on some level. (laughter)
Other things, like biology,
I took the courses.
I got an A in the course,
but that doesn't mean
I'm an expert on biology.
What I do is ... and this
is what's really fun for me.
The other aspect that really motivates me
is I get to sit and learn things
when I never learned them before.
For example, I did some videos
on entropy a few weeks ago.
Entropy was something that
I never understood properly
in high school.
I could write the right words on the exam,
but I never quite
understood what it meant.
I literally pondered it for 2 weeks.
I would call up my
thermodynamics professor friends
at Standford and MIT.
I was like, "Let's have a
conversation about entropy."
We would do that. Then, over the
course of time [unintelligible],
I was like, "Okay. Now I get entropy,"
and I would make the videos on them.
A lot of it, it's a
learning process for me,
and that's what makes it so much fun.
Female: Mr. Khan. Can you repeat
the questions that are asked?
Sal: Oh. Sorry. Just so y'all know,
the question was, "How do I know so much?"
(laughter) That was the ... Yeah.
Female: When exactly
did your YouTube videos
become the brand, Khan Academy?
When was that transition?
Sal: Oh, you're one of the few people
that refer to it as a
brand, but that's exciting.
The question is, "When
did the YouTube videos
"become the brand, Khan Academy?"
I think I was at a birthday
party for a friend.
He was the first person to say,
"What you're doing with your cousins,
"this is actually something
that could be generally useful.
"You should do something with it,
"make it into some type
of an organization."
The Khan Academy is a
non-for-profit organization,
but when he told me that,
that was the first time that
I thought about the idea,
"Wow, this could be a virtual school,
"or this could be something."
Since it's a nonprofit organization,
I was like, "Well, gee.
There's no ownership.
"How do I make sure they
don't fire me one day?"
I said, "Well, let me
name it after myself."
(laughter)
Female: How'd you develop a curriculum
for each course that could be used
for people all over the
world [unintelligible]?
Sal: The question was, "How
did I develop a curriculum?"
I actually get a lot of ...
I actually talked to
the State of California,
and that's the first question they asked,
"Where's the curriculum come from?"
It initially started very organically.
It was math and science as I had known it,
with the theory being if I'm able
to convey that understanding
in those connections,
that that's a good understanding.
YouTube had 10-minute time
limits on me, initially.
That was super fortuitous because
it forced me to 10 minutes.
What that allowed me to
do is make the concepts
very granular and short.
Miami Dade County has actually used them
for teacher training.
It's very easy to map it to
almost any curriculum now
because the videos just cover
one small concept at a time.
You could say, "Oh. The standard 2.3.2
"in the California Standards,
that's these 4 videos."
I don't have ... but some of
the things I am doing now,
I do look at textbooks.
I do look at what the AP
Curriculum, the standards are,
so I do try to make it so it's useful
for tests that people are
going to have to take.
Up there, in the [black].
Female: How do you make it available
to people [unintelligible]?
Sal: The question is, "How
do I make it available
"to people who don't speak English?"
English is the only language I speak well.
I can laughably speak
Hindi [unintelligible],
but that wouldn't do the job.
That's an excellent question.
People have come out of the wood works.
This is another thing I
actually forgot to talk about.
People have come out of the wood works
over the last 3 months to
start translating the videos.
Because, in the videos,
you don't see my face,
the translations work really well.
They look like they were natively spoken.
There's actually a chemistry
teacher in Uruguay,
who has started translating
the chemistry videos.
He set up a "Khan Academy
en Espanol" channel.
It's just happening organically.
Translators are [unintelligible]
Polish, German ...
Once again, I'm doing nothing.
All I'm just saying is, "Go ahead,"
and people are translating it.
Female: Do you still
find that there are some
children who need personal tuition?
Are you still doing that at all?
Sal: I am no longer directly interfering.
The question is, "Do I
find that there's still
"some children who need personal tuition?"
Kind of what I was used to doing
with Nadia and her brothers.
I still call them up and check in on them,
but I haven't been doing
that 1-on-1 session
with them anymore.
They're all in high school now.
They've, I think, gotten over
their hurdles, but I' not.
I think ... I don't want to make it sound
like this solves all the problems.
I think this gets a lot of
problems out of the way,
so that the personal time with a teacher
or a tutor can be a lot more productive.
I'm sure there are people
who can always benefit
from that personal instruction.
Yeah. Right here. How about
you in front? Yeah. You.
Female: When you're making the videos,
how do decide which concept
you're going to cover next?
Sal: The question is,
"When I make the videos,
"how do I decide what
concept I cover next?"
Some of it ... I get emails all the time,
and I take requests.
I'm telling this to all of y'all.
If y'all have a
particularly hairy problem,
that I haven't ... Send
it to me, seriously.
I literally put your email up,
and we'll do a video on it,
and it'll be up there.
I do take requests, but
a lot of it is my mood.
I'm doing this almost out of ...
It's fun for me, so I
do what's interesting,
where I think a lot of people
would find value from it.
The simple answer is,
what I feel like teaching
is what I teach, which is
a huge luxury, I think.
Oh, you.
Female: Where do you see
the Khan Academy going
in the next 5 or 10 years?
Sal: Yeah, where I see it going.
I could talk for another hour.
Right now, there's the videos.
I intend to keep making videos,
several hundred a year.
I really want to cover everything.
Oh, the question was, "Where
do I see Khan Academy going
"over the next 5, 10 years?"
I'm going to keep making videos.
The software piece, I want to build out.
I'm talking to some philanthropic groups
about potentially being able to
hire a small team of engineers
to build out the software
so people can practice,
and we can get data on what
works and what doesn't work.
Then, this actually ties into world peace.
What I want to do is overlay
that with the community,
where people are using the vidoes.
People are using the software,
but if they still don't get it,
the site knows what they're
having difficulty with,
and it can match them
up with someone else.
You are a 9th grader in [Taron].
You have trouble with
systems of equations.
There's a brilliant teacher
who is a 10th grader,
in Tel Aviv, and we'll
connect the two of you.
Y'all will have a session.
Y'all will talk about mathematics,
and respect each other, and do well.
As you can imagine, over time,
that can foster a whole
set of other things.
Actually, I'm talking to
these philanthropic groups
because there's potential
of going to rural villages
where you can't find algebra teachers,
where students, even if you build them
the best school on the planet,
and you give them the teachers,
they're not going to show up
because they have to
help out their families
during the harvest, or
work, or whatever else.
The idea is really have
a school-in-the-box,
where kids can learn on their own time,
and then the philanthropic group
can actually take a step back,
and the data comes back to them,
and see what the kids in the
villages are actually doing.
I envision this world-wide virtual school.
That's my dream.
It might even have physical incarnations.
But, the physical
incarnations are just places
to plug into this world-wide
school that spans all continents.
That's my dream.
Any ... right there.
Female: Have you ever felt like,
with all the [unintelligible] and stuff,
that you need to hire people to
help you with [unintelligible]?
Sal: I have, many ... The question is
"Have I ever thought that I need
to hire someone to help me?"
The answer is, yes. I have.
Right now, it's being
funded by the Salman Khan
Bank of America checking
account, (laughter)
and they're pretty stingy. (laughter)
I do want to hire people,
especially on the software side.
I've actually thought
about bringing other people
for on the content side, even in English.
It's actually harder than I thought.
I have a lot of friends who would
probably be brilliant instructors,
but something about the YouTube format,
they start to freeze up.
I think one of the big values about it
is when I started making this,
I wasn't getting paid to do it.
It wasn't stressed about it.
I was like, "This is for Nadia and Armand.
"They're going to take what I give them."
(laughter) I literally ...
I'm answering the phone.
I'm talking to telemarketers on some
of these early videos.
It has this very ...
You hear my wife yelling at me
sometimes in the background.
(laughter) It's really low-key,
but I think that's why
it's connected with people.
The answer is I would like
to hire up a small team,
probably 5 or 10 people, eventually.
Oh, our last question.
Right there in the back.
Female: Have you ever considered
visiting the rural areas
where your videos are being
watched [unintelligible]?
Sal: The question is, "Have
I ever considered visiting
"the rural areas where the videos
are being watched firsthand?"
I would love to do that.
I have an irrational fear of flying,
which I need to get over.
Other than that, I would love to.
In particular, the group in Uganda,
they seem to be doing tremendously.
They send me pictures all of the time,
but nothing would be more
exciting than to do that.
Actually, my mother's village,
which is outside of Calcutta,
I would love to ...
they're apparently using it
on some level over there as well.
I would love to go visit there,
and see how it's being used.
Thank you, very much. (applause)